Tyler Cowen professor of economics
George Mason University well I think
most people are basically selfish but
they're selfish in a way which is fairly
reasonable they want a good life for
themselves and for their immediate
family but they don't want that life at
the expense of having to be violent
against other people or having to become
an ogre so that's a mix of benevolence
and selfish and occasionally people will
do something truly wonderful or truly
saintly and that's my core model of
human nature I don't think people are
depraved but they're not always
incredibly generous either what markets
do is they give people more resources
more resources to meet ends most of
those resources they're used for selfish
ends we feed ourselves we buy clothes
for our family we built homes in my
opinion these are fundamentally healthy
impulses and we cannot rule over the
other fellow anyway we don't always know
what's good for other people so I think
for the most part the markets and
capitalist wealth help people become
more of what they are that's something
in most cases entirely acceptable there
are exceptions there are people who are
psychotics and in a market economy they
can buy a gun or is back in the Stone
Age they only had a club and that makes
society worse that's a case where
markets I wouldn't say they corrupted
the psychotic but they helped a
corrupted person be more destructive but
if you look at the world as a whole do
you see more production or do you see
more destruction in market economies I
think it's pretty clear what the answer
is you see a lot more production you see
a lot more cooperation you see a lot
more people striving after noble ends
even if it's just their own happiness
and the happiness of their families
well regulation is a very tricky word I
think obviously there's a place for
regulation in a free market just
enforcing contracts is regulation
stopping fraud if I sell you a can of
fish but it's poisoned regulation and
the legal system should do something
against that but I think in today's
world we've taken a lot of regulation
too far there's an enormous amount of
micromanagement of transactions pick up
a copy of the Federal Register it's
about this thick every day it's hundreds
of pages of micromanage regulations
often at first by bureaucrats who are
working from the outside they don't
really understand what is best for
transactions and they're not doing as
good a job at improving the quality of
our lives as we could do ourselves
I think some of the people in the
financial sector were immoral and deeply
immoral there were people who solved
packages of mortgages and knew they
weren't good there were some people who
borrowed money knowing they could never
repay it but I think the majority of
mistakes were genuinely honest mistakes
people messed up people self deceived
people were weak or people just didn't
understand but financial products are
extremely tricky and sophisticated and
it's not the case that everyone out
there was acting in a corrupt fashion
most of the people who made these
mistakes were good honest people like
you and I you know hope we are and a lot
of people have lost money probably
including the two of us but it doesn't
mean we're somehow wrong are corrupt so
mostly it was a mistake and a failure to
perceive that the world had somehow
shifted and that it had become far
riskier in a way we just weren't
understanding
why were the Treasury secretary right
now I would consider resigning and
disgrace because what Henry Paulson did
was he told us not many weeks ago that
it was necessary to purchase assets from
banks at inflated prices and that if we
didn't do this
essentially the world would come to an
end Paulson today he held a press
conference and he said we don't need to
do this anymore we're gonna spend that
money other places we're gonna subsidize
people using their credit cards which in
my opinion is crazy spending more money
it's not what we need we're gonna send
some of that money to General Motors
which i think is a lost cause at this
point and in essence the first half of
the seven hundred billion dollars that
was approved most of that money is going
to be wasted it was drummed up on the
grounds of a scare tactic some of it has
been wisely spent recapitalizing banks
but most of it has been wasted or will
be wasted it's being spent on pork it's
being spent on special interests and we
as voters were tricked misled and lied
to and if you're looking at what might
be behavior of questionable morality I
would have to look you know square down
the road at our federal government and
ask have they been honest and
transparent with us during this
financial crisis and sadly it seems more
and more every day that the answer is No
you go back and you look at world
history whenever good things have been
happening it has generally been an era
of globalization take the growth of the
Roman Empire that was a kind of
globalization of Europe take the rise of
the Renaissance that was a rebirth of
cities a reopening of trade routes the
drawing of scientific ideas from China
and from the Islamic world that was an
era of globalization take the fantastic
growth of prosperity and liberty in the
19th century or after world war ii again
you will find errors of globalization if
you want to look for d globalization
retrenchment go to the dark ages that's
what the opposite of globalization looks
like so I think we absolutely are at the
point where we need to embrace
globalization the benefits are far
greater than the costs and realize that
it's here to stay